das mal zurückkehrt fünf tode menschen
gut stark läuft bei dir einfach 50
hallo ich meine lieben freunde oder
herzlich zu einer weiteren folge biker
galaxy zusammen mit falle was geht ab
was möchtest du erreichen dieser folge
advanced ja nix anfangen anfangen
anfangen ja und ich könnte mir jetzt
endlich mal auch seine schöne weapon box
machen das habe ich die letzte freunde
irgendwie verpasst du hast du kakteen
skeptisch screen
das habe ich mir einfach aus
verschiedenen zusammen und ich hab was
hab ich genau
ich habe glaube ich gar keinen dass ich
habe einfach die blumen dafür benutzt
das ging auch wunderbar die pavane blaue
blume ja und blau-gelbe und dann ein
drache ist da ich höre den diese noch
ganz klein
deshalb bieten wir der einzige
enttäuschung war wundervoll erfolge
einen drachen aber ich musste mal kurz
hier so ein bisschen befreien
wo hast du denn den habe ich in einer
mine gefunden
jetzt habe ich aber angst dass der
drache umkehr der luft aber schon
ordentlich
ich habe noch nie in meinem ide gefunden
und drache
jetzt machen wir hier keinen kleinen
aber ich musste ihn lieber kein jetzt
hier kann ich dich jetzt für dich weg
warum jetzt könnte es nun nicht geben
das ganze kommt es erst mal meine nutzt
kiste reinholz rein ist
dürfen wir das feuer brach auf frischen
inventar ich bin noch nie wurden swords
gemacht die total abgebracht sind
schwachsinn ich wieder nicht wollte die
klopp ich gebrauchen nein die sache
läuft die ganze these längst ich
versuchte ihn in irgendeiner weise mal
ein zug ich habe das richtig witzig vor
wie einfach kann mit dem wir davon was
zeichnen wenn vermuten einen drachen
daher läuft wundervoll darin wie vor ihm
weg läuft soll ich stelle ja sagen wir
mal höher
ich kann ihr keinen ball palm hinsetzen
gehst du auf sand das kann er sein mag
daher wurde eingesperrt operation
erfolgreich kann ich keinem nur sand
setzen
das weiß ich gar nicht da kann ich mich
gar nicht so sehr palm ja kann ich otto
ausgebrochen marke palm fahren wie lieb
ich dich da irgendwie wieder zurück
drücken wird es natürlich nicht sein
name wir müssen noch meinen namen suchen
leute ich vorschläge natürlich wie immer
gerne unten rein und bitte lieber drache
laufe nicht weg ich muss ich muss hier
ein bisschen dna farm ja schon jetzt die
palme mein haus herum wunderschöne
atmosphäre hier kommt noch ein bisschen
von diesem boot rhein bei mir jetzt
einfach mal dahin wussten da kann schon
sagen dass geklauter stier glaubt meine
minions haben mich verarscht
ich finde man auch nicht mehr wieder
aber meine sollten eigentlich wollte man
angst haben den minions dann wenn die da
hinten aber diesmal ich werde es aber
mal gucken am samstag
ich gucke jetzt erst mal ganz kurz ob
ich jetzt etwas anpflanzen kann was
könnt ihr mit kokosnüssen machen
er ist auch trophy kräftner ja genau
vale konnten pflanzlich man kaffee und
strawberry und reis normales so eine
kleine farm können die ihr können dir
auf jeden fall sowie noch vier freie das
heißt ich kann noch
strawberry hier jetzt mal hier dennoch
zieht dann macht ihr komplett cacau denn
meine tolle cookies cookies woher kommt
das alles hin dann hier noch dass solch
ein kleines fabel and mensch sieht
wunderschön aus eigentlich eine
wunderschöne fahrt kommen mal wenn ich
da drauf gesteht sogar groß wie weit er
schon gewachsen ist wundervoll
wundervoll gefällt mir so jetzt soll ich
mir noch so ein bisschen holz wo ich
habe mich hat erschreckt meine blöden
minions haben irgendwas abgabe der mich
gerade geschlagen
die hunde die wissen wie die schlawiner
das mache ich mit kokosnüssen kann ich
mir damit so einer colada machen da
müsstest du einfach mal drücken und
gucken wie du den den masten schrieb
einmal pina colada ein und dann wusste
dass irgendwann dort erscheinen
mal gucken wie ich hier rauskomme er das
ist immer ein kampf cool ich habe direkt
neue setzlinge bekommen das freut mich
mein bestes album stone ich glaube die
leute meinten obwohl nicht hier sind die
fossil sachen leute ihr könnt ihr
übrigens auch wieder dinge schreiben in
die kommentare am besten mit sonder man
kann jetzt richtig viel schreiben bei
youtube blog ich sogar damals ganze so
eine begrenzung aber mittlerweile kann
man richtig viel schreiben und wenn ihr
de welche tipps hat bezüglich
irgendwelchem aus wo er sagt das könnte
ich interessieren dann schreibt mir das
einfach und prallen und dann werde ich
wundervoll begeistert davon
hattest du dich beim mega projekt mit
tinkers construct auseinandergesetzt was
ist das das ist auch so eine mod die
glaube ich auch beim mega projekt dabei
war die hat eine theorie dann könntest
du dir so richtig krasse waffen auch
bauen eben auch wie diesen api und so
wovon wir in der letzten folge hat
mehrere notenbanker brennt näher aber
dann kannst du eben auch irgend so eine
so eine spitzhacke die so mega krasse
attribute hatte gab schon schon
schmackhafte sachen wir hatten
also ich hab mir so richtig viele dinge
gebaut die einfach auch dieses mit denen
mit dem pulver reiser der dann die ärzte
wirklich verdoppelt hat man noch nie
hatte ich glaube ich auch das ganze land
angetrieben mit generatoren dann hatte
ich auch noch so priebs die ganze items
befördert haben dann hatte ich noch so
einem einigen turtle die mir immer so
ein riesiges loch gegraben hat und weder
die uns items rausgeholt hat und so was
alles okay ich habe da noch mal
irgendwie video zur angucken ja schon
gesagt noch informieren
damit hier man das bei mir auch ein
wenig gucken kann ich möchte ganz kurz
gucken was macht dir dieses backpacker
überhaupt ist als jetzt hin
es kann ja berechtigt auch das wie die
kiste noch mehr platz ist größer
verkleinert und sticks also ich glaube
diesen sogar richtig warum ich das jetzt
abbau ist das dann irgendwie ironisch
gute hallo wir sollten das jetzt wieso
gehen lassen ein bisschen runter immer
von der haltbarkeit was ihr drohen
nördlich ich habe ein backpack und
eigentlich kann ein backpacker das ist
ja so wie die kiste das kann ja keiner
haltbarkeit haben das geht ja nicht
kaputt sein läge klingt klingt relativ
logisch und es geht kaputt
irgendwas ist das ist fünf tote mensch
so gut läuft bei dir halt einfach 15
scraper das ist jetzt bei mir noch ein
bisschen advance genetics jetzt muss ich
nämlich eigentlich mal ein paar obwohl
wir holen uns erst mal merken gefeiert
das wäre vielleicht keine keine
schlechte wahl
ich hab das voll
ja ich wollte jetzt auch eine schlaufe
machen
münchen die blumen vergraben kann weil
keiner will seine visage sehen
so handelt sich jetzt mal backpack
nehmen backpack das ist ja holz das pack
ich jetzt meine holzkiste da sie meinen
stuhl palma werde ich eben das und jetzt
kommt hier auch überall dorthin hat
machst was muss jetzt endlich gerade
seinen plan was ist da wirklich frei ich
habe schon erfahren gesagt wir zwar
keiner bei zugucken arbeit bauen wir ein
haus acht ein hus also es wird immer
schöner ich habe jetzt sogar schon hier
so weiß fischer als parkett gelegt
pakete parkett war schon alles
schallgedämmt hier falls ich hier rum
aufnehmen möchte in meinem haus hier
da wird es hier nicht so viel halt wer
soll diese schallplatten für 300 euro
gekauft denn die kosten also
schallschutz platin-schallplatten ist
was er isst junge so schallschutz
platten die kosten erst richtig viel
kapital informiert weil in meiner neuen
wohne ich hab da ein bisschen angst ist
es ein bisschen halt deswegen wollte mir
so schallschutz platten holen der kosten
sechs stück einfach 300 euro der fado
das ist das ist so krass ist immer in
meinen mikrofon mit meinem nicht pult
und mit meinem kompressor mischpult hat
zusammen 300 euro kostet wer kann mir
oder ich hab jetzt auch ein neues
mikrofon herausgesucht was mir eventuell
holen wollte kostet 300 euro ob ich mir
an schallschutz platten hole oder ein
neues mikrofon dann kommt dann ruhig wir
lieber 3000 teppiche die ich alle wand
hänge ab wie du mich oder eierkartons
eierkarton stimmt oder einfach so
styropor aber sportlich so gar nicht mal
so gesund muss einfach gut vielleicht
hat es ja auch gar nicht was manchmal
das was sie früher immer in die in die
wände getan haben was was nicht asbest
auch aber bisher als best rein
das passt ja das ist so das haben sie
früher ganz oft in wände etc getan auch
für die dämmung oder irgendwas isolation
und das war eben stark krebserregend das
war nicht ganz so optimal für mich ja
das ist bestimmt auch das kriegst du
bist ja auch noch günstig irgendwo gehör
geschenkt ist geschenkt kriegt es
bestimmt
jetzt jedoch zu sein ich weiß nicht ich
glaube ich jeder ganz einfach jedoch zur
seite rüber vor anderen seite dann nicht
oder ich weiß gar nicht ob man auch mal
hier war immer noch so ein komisches
herum ich glaube das gehört niemandem
bei dem ab was ist dein rechtes einfach
rettete das ist an bord ist also fast
alles arrangiert strom mittels haus was
sie einfach völlig weggesprengt wurde
und ich habe eben gerade so ein bisschen
dna gesammelt beziehungsweise nächsten
zellen sind das noch dna kommt dann erst
später bzw
helix gucken wir sollten das jetzt hier
so lang ist nicht mal sachen drin müssen
denn seine ganze sache
ich bin nicht sicher ob das passiert so
da geht es am so kurvig kommt dann noch
so ein neuer raum hin ist ja noch gar
nicht was ich in die jeweiligen räume
machen solle
nur kurz wurde den sattel durfte ich mir
von von stocker nehmen das ist alles
alles alles klappt lauten die kommentare
also bei sturm waffel müsste da
schreiben bei lugano muss mein achter
unten ist man auch in kleinen
herzinfarkt und er habe schneidet ein
anderes tier gesucht wurde achter
nein nein der krippe steht der
attackiert den drachen nicht ok bin darf
ich auf gar keinen fall verlieren wenn
ich so traurig dann weine ich ja noch
ein video von mache ich im video
das geht zu oft mittlerweile denken alle
leute wenn in hamburg wundert sich auch
unbedingt nach hamburg nebel ruhig zu
hause beiden und pflicht wir sind die
einzigen tool beuster genau die beastie
boys so skins teils in den dna analyzer
tun dass das mache ich doch hier ach ich
brauche hier noch achten ist jetzt habe
ich natürlich vergessen werden sogar mit
bast scho generate zutrauen darf da
braucht ja auch irgendwie energie paket
so geht das ja nicht hast du nicht so
ein thema engine oder irgend sowas ja
die habe ich über aber dies auf einer
anderen ebene
und das wäre jetzt einfach so ein com
bastian generate abbauen hier sind meine
minions auch noch die sind sind sie
zurückgekommen
tatsächlich leute dann drückt nochmal
ein bisschen bisschen so dann mache ich
hier also nur kurz bei mir jetzt ich
mache dann hier sind vorne so eine
ahnung was in seinem wintergarten
ähnliches teil
die statue werde ich dann irgendwie
nochmal hier vorne drauf setze ich mir
noch jemand einfallen lassen und das
ganze wird dann hier voll gekleistert
mit glas was jetzt gerade in den ofen
eigentlich schon sehr weit sein sollte
er 36 grad habe ich schon mal
ich verwahre mich ein ganz kurz zurück
dass ich auf einer höhe bin mit dem
ganzen graz war sich die veranstalter
und hier hinten kommt dann hinten von
hand und ich hätte es mir auch einmal
passiert ich bin auch am ende dann auch
gestorben
aber das waren leute das haben alle
gesehen dass man bereits an bug und hier
kommt eine glaswand hinten damit ihr
euch das mal ein bisschen vorstellen
können und hier kommt dann noch so ein
raum mit lege ich dann wahrscheinlich
mein bett rein weil darum hinten kann
ich dann immer so schön
nee da geht die sonne doch aufgenommen
der mond unter da geht der mond unter
dem sich jedoch trotzdem hier mein bett
zimmer hin und da wird alles wunderschön
hoffe ich einfach müssten auch pause
gleich wer die folge beendet ist geht
bei mir immer so schnell vorbei das
unglaublich man ja bald vielleicht nur
ein stunden folge zusammen während du da
leistung wartet und dann nehme ich
einfach auf das kind nach dem plan sowie
ein bisschen ich hoffe mal das soll er
in sein diese normale fledermaus endlich
hat man sogar auf popcorn hätte ich auch
nichts ging ich habe aber auch einfach
hunger dementsprechend würde ich jetzt
glaube ich alles wenn ich in letzter
zeit hunger will ich etwas ungesundes
essen was richtig geschmeckt nun also so
ungesund es gibt um gesündere sachen als
popcorn
ja aber es ist jetzt auch nicht weil es
ist einfach nur gezuckerte weiß gerne
naja den fcs mich immer man wird sagen
groß und stark wird ich bin beides schon
ziemlich kaputt 2 ich will nicht die
folge beenden weil ich so viel machen
will
ich hänge aber auch alle so ein bisschen
wie viel minuten sind wir denn ich muss
noch ganze passiert zwei minuten kriegen
alles hin es geht der ärger dass die
folge zu langen hier und bei mir ist
mittlerweile einfach jede folge ein
bisschen zu können jetzt kommen die
skins als nach ein und dann funktionär
weißt du so läuft das muss auf jeden
fall da oben jetzt bei mir da ist hat
mir die eher abgebaut
da kommt jetzt noch etwas anders denn da
kommt was kann ich dann an die decke
machen was für materialien mit denen die
wiesn kronleuchter bei minecraft kenne
sie und habe auch schon lampen gesucht
und es gibt auch lampen das ist sehr
schön
der kommt dann aber etwas anderes hin
die ganze stadt konnte dann auch noch
weg und dann kommt da oben eine decke
und dann habe ich in drei blog hohen
raum und dann ist es somit schreibt mal
das ist das schönste haus ist dann fühle
ich mich bestätigt es ist wundervoll ich
bin in samberg und kann zu allen seiten
hingucken das ist sehr sehr geil
soweit ich bin ich bin gespannt auf die
folgen weil ich hab' ich kenne ja auch
deinen berg ich hab da auch schon mal
eine folge bei dir gesehen
surprise es ist wirklich sehr schön aus
bei dir
ich gehe mal runter ach so ja sorry das
kind dabei irgendwas müssen wir haben
schon wieder überzogen aber noch wie ich
hole mir leid darüber dümpelte geprüft
egal freunde wenn es euch trotzdem
wichtig trotzdem gefallen hat dann könnt
ihr jetzt gern zeigen über eine
bewertung und schreibt uns in die
kommentare
dem piloten was er guckt einfach bei mir
schreibt mir bitte ihnen was ich machen
kann mit mods gut erklärt und dann will
ich sagen tschüss